he looked nailed on to lead you Kip into
its post brexit post nigel Faraj future
that was until an incident with a fellow
party member left him in hospital and
led to one of the most dramatic party
resignations of recent years now Stephen
wolf is getting back into frontline
politics with a new report on
immigration after we leave the EU he
joins me now in the studio hello thank
you for being with us this morning
now before we get on to the immigration
report in the future of UK plan I'm keen
to get your thoughts on the really big
and important story of the week's Styria
yeah Nigel frosh and Paul Nutter are
both really spoken out against Donald
Trump so move to launch these airstrikes
in response to the gas attack what's
your position I think in terms of the
general politics of the United States
this is actually sowed the seeds of
Trump losing the next election because
it was absolutely clear that we've
Bannon and others supporting this
America first kind of concept that that
meant no intervention in other countries
it meant having an opening with with
Russia so he's gone back on his word and
I think people will see not only that
he's gone back in his word but he
actually looks more like the Democrats
that he argued so vehemently before but
there's also an important thing that he
kind of see here is the power of Kushner
now in terms of Jared Kushner coming in
there and saying look it's it's me now
I've been able to influence my
father-in-law to make this decision and
there's one common that says that Bannen
accused Kushner of actually being a
Democrat and that this would damage and
I think that's the long-term
consequences in the United States and
moving on now six months ago you were
seen as the future of you kept the
leader in Waiting post Nigel Faraj and
then in a pretty remarkable couple of
days we saw you knocked out cold on the
floor of the European Parliament
you resigned from the party and to be
honest we haven't really heard much from
you since so where have you been hiding
well I think I needed to take some time
out it was a dramatic and dramatic
period for me I've worked incredibly
hard across the past six years for
YouTube we've worked really hard for the
referendum I'll spend
you know hours and hours every single
day working with some brilliant people
and for me too to see what happened in
the party at that time wants Nigel are
resigned not just myself but there are
other decent people like Nathan Gill
being attacked in Wales the way that
they treated Diane James it was a period
for me to say no I've got to step back
think about what's happening and
consider how I can support brexit this
is something that I've worked on and
that is why I've now worked with a
number of people for a good period of
time to produce this report which will
be in my view a template for this
government to achieve what British
people want it leaving Breck see keeping
immigration reducing the numbers and
having ourselves open to the world so
this is the report that you're launching
today saying that you want to get net
migration down to 50,000 a year now the
OB are the official a political
independent analysis and analysts have
said that getting immigration down to an
even bigger number than what you're
saying would have a huge hit on the
economy 16 billion pounds so are you
prepared there to see billions of pounds
more borrowing in order to get net
migration down we see that's one aspect
of the reports that the OB job have done
but in the research that I've looked at
I don't believe that will actually be
the case because that takes a view that
will have masses of people leaving this
country and I don't believe that those
people have come from the European
countries they're now settle communities
they'll be here I think there needs to
be a real important training program
going on we have eight hundred and
twenty six thousand young people 16 to
24 without a job and they'll be a clear
recognition that Theresa May has already
started this we can see that for
apprenticeship schemes and training
programs that they will be brought back
into the system as well so I think
they're really putting out not a fear
program obviously I think they've just
been a little bit too extreme in what
would actually happen the program I've
got in place will actually have a gentle
progression there's another thing that
I'm slightly confused about in your
ports I'm hoping you might be able to
clear this up now you say in the report
there should be no further restrictions
on student immigration but also that
students should still be included in
that target you still want to get a net
migration down to 50,000 a year because
net emigration of students haven't
hasn't believed been below that target
for the last five years been last year
for example it was 70,000 so your whole
target would be used up and more
probably know by students no no no
because this is something I tried to set
out in in the back of the report with
the numbers you have to consider also
the amount of emigration that we have so
if you have emigration which is over
three hundred and twenty seven thousand
you take off the students you add those
on asylum you add those with family
reunion we're already in a net migration
situation so the only number that puts
us into a positive net migration
situation the numbers that we have at
the moment is work and those who are
coming here to work so that is the area
you've got to target and my belief is
that we have around a hundred thousand
visas coming in each year and we only
have four thousand highly skilled
entrepreneurs now ninety six thousand in
terms of we're talking about net
emigration of students here so it is
over that it's last year was seventy
thousand yes but what I'm saying we have
three hundred and twenty seven thousand
in terms of emigration deduct the net
the students from that and you already
have net migration which is down below a
hundred thousand their add-on asylum add
on family reunion and you keep creeping
up towards that zero point and that is
where you've got to be looking at the
work it's to coming in and I believe
that we can have highly-skilled workers
into this country with a really dominant
and important point based system a
British workers visa system which is has
at its core a fair flexible and
forward-thinking philosophy and an idea
of bringing net migration down will work
for our country
now I'm keen to talk about UK we were
saying that six months ago you were seen
as the future of you kit now since then
things have been very difficult for the
party you had the leader are failing to
win that by-election that really many
people criticized on the campaign that
was run there you've lost your only MP
post brexit do you really think there's
any reason for you to exist anymore well
I believe that there should be a reason
for YouTube to exist I wouldn't have
wanted to stand if I didn't think that
and that is because there is a large
number of people in this country who
don't trust the Labour Party don't trust
the Conservative Party and actually feel
as though they've been left out or left
behind and it is you keep serving those
people now I don't think they are at the
moment which is a really sad thing about
I think their messages are mixed I mean
take for example on immigration this is
one of the big
issues they've they've got a person who
you never even hear about in terms of
immigration in charge of that policy and
they should be driving
we're like actually I think it's their
treasurer yeah and literally they're not
pushing the issues that matter and
that's because they're still fractured
they're losing members they're losing
people who supported them they're losing
votes and that shouldn't have happened
and all of this was caused by the
infighting that occurred the desire to
drive out decent people in the party and
I think now what they can see that they
were duped by an MP who didn't want you
Kip to be at the front of the brexit
campaign at all you're blaming douglas
Carswell there and do you think that
nigel frosh also needs to share some
responsibility for the infighting that
really has Riven UK I think everybody
has a responsibility and I would
probably have to save myself at that
stage because people were trying to
argue different positions on that and
what is that Nigel frost what night
Nigel made a very clear point that he he
said be careful of Douglas because
Douglas wanted to damage the the
referendum campaign Douglas own words
has said that that was one of his
intentions now as we see from reports
the real responsibility is those people
in the National Executive Committee who
were receiving all those who were
employed by the party of large sums of
money who were duped by that or desired
a different person in the leadership and
we're not willing to listen to those who
had greater experience than themselves
or had to face the real politic of the
day of having to meet other politicians
and see what was happening what's your
relationship like now then with their
people in UK I still have a pretty
reasonable relationship with the
membership I get some positive comments
all the time well within the UK kind of
politic I have probably about half a
dozen Emmy Emmy pees that I still have
lunch and have drinks with I have a chat
with Nigel from time to time
obviously he keeps his distance from me
a little bit but for a vast majority of
them sadly no they see me as some sort
of pariah it's it's bit schoolboy ish
but I've learned that's some things that
happens in politics sadly and I think we
should have big enough shoulders and
broad enough shoulders to move on I've
certainly tried to do that
and the way I'm looking at the sun's out
we've got some we're coming Breck's it's
on its way
true so may is doing a vest and we just
got to make sure that we battle against
those remainders who seek the negativity
about Britain instead of seeing what a
great country we are are moving forward
well the Sun is undoubtedly out this
weekend it's to come thank you very much